in my not so humble opinion far cry 4 is
everything Far Cry 3 wanted to be its
bigger more sandbox e more packed to the
gills with interesting combat scenarios
topological features environments and
characters but perhaps the greatest
improvement to this open world series is
the inclusion of a truer form of coop so
I'm running down the five reasons you
have to play Far Cry 4 coop because
everything is better with a buddy
especially murder the first thing that
occurred to me as I dove into coop was
how intensely the planning escalated for
my single-player approach sure enough
that patented Far Cry chaos typically
takes over with little regard for the
best laid plans but there was a certain
satisfaction and attempting to
coordinate a strike or a stunt with
utter precision and then actually
pulling it off there are a few things
more delightful than silently executing
an entire cave of guards without a
single Higa especially when it's done
exactly according to plan no matter how
many attempts it takes in fact the more
times we attempted a particular strike
the more eager I was to succeed with our
plans of silent assassination there are
ample opportunities for approaches like
this beyond the smash and grab tactics
certain situations allow for you to
rappel into the thick of an enemy base
from above or approach from a flanking
position in the Hills or you know just
say [ __ ] it and drive right in with some
explosives and oh oh nice Herc thanks
for that though that was very helpful my
second point may logically follow from
the first but it's important enough to
merit its own spot on this list
assaulting the various outposts and
fortresses around kirat has provided the
majority of my favorite moments in coop
thus far the abundance of these
locations as well as the variety and
their difficulty in makeup makes them a
huge chunk of Far Cry 4s best content
much like the planning approach stage
the actual act of taking a base allows
you seemingly infinite variety in your
approach with a friend alongside
reinforcements on route banish them to
hell with a mortar well your buddy lays
down some mines cage Tigers in the base
antagonize him with a hunk of meat and
let your partner snipe the stragglers
run out RPGs have your partner hop on
the mounted machine gun while you fly up
and shoot that pilot in his stupid mouth
feeling especially ballsy ride dual
elephants into oh [ __ ] maybe that one
was a bad idea I am so sorry the
boundless number of methods for raising
these bases makes it a joy to mix and
match strategies with your partner and
devise new ways to conquer them
even getting from A to B in the world of
Korat is too good when you've got a
buddy alongside you the wingsuit is
available surprisingly early on and
makes every descent something to look
forward to as you race each other down
the Himalayan slopes the driving is also
pretty tight and you can even switch on
autopilot if you're particularly
lazy-ass or need to take some potshots
or just let your buddy do the shooting
and focus on the road Kurata is also
littered with gyrocopters that shorten
your travel time and as you can imagine
up the sandbox factor quite a bit and
you can grapple the bottom of these
things I repeat you can grapple onto the
bottom of a goddamn [ __ ] helicopter
in fact this may be my favorite
discovery so far one of the most
unexpectedly fun aspects of co-op is the
wildlife presence in Quran this is the
environments wild card element I rarely
thought about the animals of korat while
I was actually playing but then out of
nowhere an eagle would try to claw out
my partner's eyeballs or Rhino would
Gore enemy troops nearby the ability to
ride tandem elephants is also one of the
best most pointless things I've ever
experienced and more importantly
defeating hordes of honey badgers all of
the footage do the talking on that one
the most essential aspect of far craft
co-op is the sense of adventure that
permeates the entire experience its
open-world 101 that if you want a
sandbox game like this to succeed just
[ __ ] around in the world needs to be
an experience worth having and oh god is
it even without a sense of purpose as
you wander kirat aimlessly
vignettes present themselves to you at
every turn each little encounter turns
itself into an individual story there
are secret caverns to rappel into random
groups of foes to defeat a litany of
spontaneously generated world events
caves obscured by waterfalls hostages to
rescue wingsuit routes to shred and
boundaries to push and it's all that
much better with a buddy to experience
it with the conversation and laughter
that this game Spurs is unlike anything
I've played in years and even if it was
just a sandbox tech demo with no story
content at all I would still have a
blast just testing the limits of Far Cry
4s world alongside a friend alas nothing
lasts forever
not even a murder fuelled love that
burns like the Sun good night sweet
prince